[Música]
cuando nos dijeron que el tema de este
año era la curiosidad enseguida pensamos
pues igual o resulta curioso saber qué
es lo que sentimos con nuestro trabajo
que es lo que nos pasa por dentro cuando
estamos actuando así italia como hoy un
escenario un público queréis saber lo
que nos ocurre
pues no lo vamos a contar
no porque hoy queremos que lo viváis en
primera persona hoy os invitamos a que
actuase con nosotros atención porque hoy
aquí cuatrocientas personas vais a hacer
una actuación esto lo vamos a grabar y
lo va a ver medio planeta sin presión
ninguna
además sabéis que ha venido gente de
télex de toda españa de otros países que
han venido a posta a veros a observar a
observar si les gusta no vamos todos de
gira todos ustedes en autobús el 400 y
exactamente así que nada es así para que
os sintáis la actuación desde el mismo
momento para que sintáis protagonistas
os vamos a dar a elegir entre dos
canciones para poder actuar
luego votaremos saber cuál es la que más
os llena y preparados privadas pues
venga vamos con la primera canción
escuchamos
y era una canción real la crisis
vamos con la segunda bueno la segunda yo
solamente escucharla ya me entra un
picor por dentro es como tener de actuar
es una canción muy conocida de una banda
sonora de una película
esta canción ya avisó aviso ya que yo
aquí no voy a poder aguantar menos
dentro del círculo yo cuando escucho
este espacio necesito quedarme ahí en el
centro pueda tener bailar recuerda
las tres normas télex o si tiene una
buena idea
no te pases de 18 minutos y la más
importante jamás salgas del círculo de
verdad si las tres normas como logren
sí sí sí sí no
así que mejor es mejor que no sea yo ahí
para mí desde aquí arriba
esto de aquí de aquí para allá es como
un abismo está oscuro es corre el viento
es como morder
miedo es que no lo sabéis pero no
no puedo esperar a mí a mí no me pillan
pero de momento los señores del té de
c's hay un vacío legal en cuanto a
puntos rojos
tenéis que revisar en ningún momento
pone que es solamente es un punto número
de puntos rojos en ningún vacío legal
venga ahora sí preparados todos porque
porque vamos con la segunda opción vamos
allá
[Música]
número 30 lentes
mejor vamos con las votaciones gracias
risas
alguien quiere la primera canción
contracciones para la primera canción
[Música]
la atención votaciones para la segunda
canción de fútbol bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien por votación popular está claro la
primera canción es la elegida la segunda
en el momento momento momento momento
que ya tenéis vuestra canción por actuar
no por un momento pero qué ha pasado
aquí
pero esto no va esto no va de esto nueva
de curiosidad el ser humano no es
curioso por naturaleza habéis elegido la
segunda canción que era la que ya
conocéis y la primera o la primera es la
bomba vamos a la primera es tal cual una
danza faulí que viene de costa de marfil
que sea es una danza espectacular se
habla con unas máscaras bellísimas y
además un baile súper rápido de piernas
y además es patrimonio inmaterial de la
humanidad
del patrimonio y full monty
ahora lo que tenéis en contra de nuestra
música goza origen no ven una vamos allá
vamos a ver yo creo yo creo que igual lo
que ha pasado lo que ha pasado que
despierte una oportunidad tremenda
shawn holley e igual lo que ha pasado es
que yo igual me venía un poquito arriba
entonces igual yo sin querer sin querer
y guiado vuestra curiosidad la he
conducido hacia la opción que a mí más
me interesaba no esperaba que yo quería
grabar que me gusta manito eso es una
gran noticia porque estamos viendo que
la curiosidad por tanto se contagia por
tanto la curiosidad se aprende y lo más
importante la curiosidad se enseña y esa
ayuda hacia dónde queremos llevar
nuestra charla que en nuestra mano en
cada uno de nosotros y nosotros está la
posibilidad de contagiar curiosidad y es
lo que hemos llamado la atención al
nombre para que se os quede cuando
salgáis de aquí esperamos que seáis
embajadores de la curiosidad si así es
embajadores de la unidad que llega
embajadores de la curiosidad aquí
tenemos a 400 posibles embajadores de la
curiosidad pero ojo cuidado porque entre
entre la curiosidad por saber de algo
que no conocemos y el miedo a lo
desconocido caro y una línea muy fina
entonces de qué depende que algo
realmente nos causa curiosidad porque ya
hemos visto que el objeto en sí mismo no
tiene por qué porque la primera canción
no ha sido capaz de atraer nuestra
curiosidad entonces pero que depende
vamos a poner un ejemplo venga vamos a
visualizarlo vamos a quitarle a esta
historia que vamos a contar el mismo
ingrediente que hemos quitado a la hora
de presentar la canción africana si
venís y descubrir cuáles no hace falta
situación
hijo túmbate en la cama
siéntate túmbate siempre de papá y mamá
tiene que contarte algo
papá mamá papá papá mamá soya
la cuestión es que tenemos que contarte
ante esta noche mientras duermes va a
entrar un señor por tu habitación
allanamiento de morada lo más fácil es
que entré por la ventana
ese señor no lo conoces
pero él a ti sí porque te vigila
o sea todo el año saber si otras cosas
bien o hace las cosas mal baja y si te
pillan mejor que te pille durmiendo los
papás son que oigamos realización no
vamos a entrar no voy a ser que se
enfade el hombre de que llevamos algo
llevó un saco va de rojo una barba
blanca y un gorro así un poquito región
así es que bueno hijo por nada pasaba
una noche
de nada te queremos vamos a contarle
esto a tu hermana pequeña
en dos semanas entran por la ventana 3
y con camellos
veis lo que falta el ingrediente que
falta el niño estaría que pasa es que mi
hijo es curioso
cuál es el ingrediente que nos falta
para que algo nos resulte terrorífico
como la canción africana del principio o
la navidad en este caso o que nos
despierte la curiosidad qué es lo que
falta
es lo mismo que nuestros padres madres
abuelos abuelas nos ponían y no y no
escatimaban en nada la ilusión a contar
contarnos las historias la emoción esa
es la llave es la clave para que algo
realmente cause curiosidad a los demás
y hablando de emoción vamos a ver por
qué estamos emocionados verdad bueno
pues ahora os vamos a contar cómo son
los pasos de baile así es que por favor
todo el mundo en pie vamos a rodados
entre todos en pie es muy fácil vamos a
ver la canción la conocéis la película
sonará algunos algunas entonces es muy
sencillo los pasos nos podemos todo
mirado a la izquierda eso estos en línea
bien colocaditos conformarlas bien
es muy sencillo
es muy fácil hombro hombre hombro hombro
pie pie muy sencillos
[Música]
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
parece que no
hasta que también nosotros venimos
arriba
[Aplausos]
bueno
pensar por un momento en los embajadores
de la curiosidad que habéis tenido a lo
largo de la vida gracias a ellos
guardamos todavía muchas pasiones
aficiones e incluso profesiones y sin
duda nos hicieron un gran regalo y ahí
está nuestra pero también el poder
seguir con ese legado pero claro podemos
ser embajadores de distintos niveles
diferenciamos entre el embajador amateur
el mba
tenemos un pequeño el embajador
profesional
[Música]
apoyado y científicamente caro
nos perdemos el pasador amateur y
profesional se inhibe el experto experto
exactamente y vamos a contaros la
diferencia mirad esto es muy importante
mirar esto para cuando sabéis fuera y
seis embajadores tenéis que saber qué
tipo de pasadores soy porque tengo que
ir a lo máximo mirar el embajador
amateur es ese que te dice mira he ido a
ver un museo y que me he visto he visto
un concierto
he hecho un viaje pero tiene un error
cometen un error y es que acaban
diciendo tienes que probarlo
[Música]
tenemos que quedar
si no vemos eso eso no va a ningún lado
pero sin embargo el embajador
profesional es ese que no sólo invita
sino que te acompaña a la experiencia es
el que te dice guarda este fin de semana
tengo 2 entradas compradas te recojo a
las 8
ese es el embajador profesional que
acompaña sigamos hablando de acompañar
os invitamos a que nos acompañéis vamos
ahora a retomar lo que ya sabéis que ya
está dicho muy bien y os acompañamos os
invitamos a que nos acompañéis en la
última parte de la canción todos sabemos
esta ciudad
sabéis que tenéis que elegir una prenda
la que queráis y puedes quitar la de
elegir leyes y ojalá cogéis coges una
prenda y ella como conoce el molinete
muy bien perfecto si coge había prendas
que una pena todos cogerás todos por
aquí también todos objeto de lo que
puede ser una zapatilla puede ser una
bufanda puede ser deseado es importante
después de los pasos
arriésgate arriesgado
entonces el momento final diremos
molinete
y aquí es donde nos dirán del derecho
de nuestro último gracias y un placer
molinete para arriba así para 1 lanzamos
y nos tiene que caer en el mismo punto
que estamos porque no sale entonces
sí pero espera espera porque es que el
embajador profesional si cuando se pone
en marcha es imparable y jamás jamás
acepta un no por respuesta
bueno esto no lo sabían nos gustaría que
los embajadores de la curiosidad esos
diez embajadores de hoy tuviéramos una
respuesta
[Aplausos]
claro
por aquí venir
[Aplausos]
el embajador profesional algo
maravilloso
aquí mirando para allá voy dando para
allá todo muy bien mirando para allá
qué maravillas es que se nota que lo que
decía lo que decía perdón que el
embajador profesional es aquel que es
capaz de dejar esa sensación en los
demás de no sé muy bien hacia dónde me
llevas pero yo te acompaña la confianza
es una de las claves para generar
curiosidad al final la curiosidad igual
no es más que nosotros mismos eso sí en
nuestra mejor versión de nosotros mismos
así es que ahora sí oye que puede ser
que luego no podamos contagiarlo eso
dependerá también del gusto de cada cual
de sus experiencias de sus contextos
circunstancias pero al menos nosotros
como embajadores hemos cumplido con
nuestra misión de tratar de acercar
aproximar nuestras inquietudes y
nuestras pasiones
así
una última cosa una última cosa ser
embajador de la curiosidad obviamente es
completamente altruista pero cuantas más
experiencias consigamos que los que nos
acompañan en la vida tengan cuanto más
crezcan ellos más creceremos todos así
es que vamos allá preparados en ese
momento nos falta alguien damos paso a
los voluntarios que en estados donde las
ganas notarios a personal aislada nos
que también van a bailar por supuesto en
ahora si todos ahora si todos en pie
todos entre todos siempre vamos allá
todo el mundo preparado todo mirando
para allá para ayudarles para allá todo
el mundo preparada la pregunta de otros
pero dejar los móviles leche que tenés
claro es que hemos acordado se va de
momento todo el mundo está ahí a línea
muy bien
estoy bonito cónico de todo bueno
bien
y todo el mundo
actitudes que exactamente no nos lo
vamos de gira y acordados
hombro hombro a hombro a hombro
izquierdo
[Música]
más
para la
[Música]
querida
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sabes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esperamos todo el mundo
el momento
para no no no es que nos falta por
explica el embajador experto en lenguas
y ha bajado en experto es aquel que
consigue hacer de la experiencia un
éxito y que la gente tenga ganas de
repetir y además se convierten en
embajadores entonces organizadores del
td se le estáis creo que tenemos grabar
la charla con éxito sí no
[Aplausos]
organizado en el fedex hay un vacío
legal con respecto al striptease
exactamente eso no es así
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os apuntáis a ser embajadores de la
curiosidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]